that's the most pathetic of FLT I can
say it however I want I'm not gonna talk
about the future no there's no reason
though save your money spend it in there
means the quarter digital store is live
right now guys whether you know it or
not today is our very first day that our
store is live you can get this t-shirt
and many more on corridor digital comm
slash store now this shirt is very
special because it is the only because
this is the only time guys you can get
this shirt you get 10 days 10 days left
to get this very shirt on a port or
digital icon / story well ever want to
be a dad well now you can with a
corridor digital dad hat we're making
jiff porridge but foraging for gifs
everyone wants to know how you pronounce
the letters gif and let me give you an
example of hey Peter make up a word what
the flappin don't you mean gif Lathan I
can say it however I want this is the
third annual or second annual corridor
digital gift competition thank you guys
so much for your submissions we had
quite a few there's 150 of you we
haven't seen any of them yet this is
more of a roast of our fans than again
my entry to the gift contest is any
drumroll
that's before download it and before oh
my gosh there they don't teach kids
computers these days what does it say
sorry in the matrix no if they don't
know how to make a gift how can it even
be a gift
yep unnecessary subtitles whoops forgot
to compress it next is it not a gift or
it's a poorly compressed gif it's
disqualified when there's so many when
the rendered he didn't use W come on let
me let me close that window for you fan
Ravi verse reading verse reading you
don't worry Polly some gems
I can appreciate that this may not be
but I'm sorry
yeah it's like heartbreak see mike is
not a human he's the nicest how is he
the nicest dude if he's not a human dude
so love to be human
hey dude and humanist dudes not mutually
exclusive YouTube video was the first
submission like this she says promise it
says promise oh that's weird sign of
weakness and if you don't know how to
make a gift
google it and shame pretty pretty you
can email
you guys hold it pretty funny it's for
the video that's really funny
oh there's just a reactive thing and to
make it look like they're falling in
love later see how you forged out some
air
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Christian what am I looking at over here
we're looking at the new corridor
digital pullover sweater huh and I'm
gonna go on and get answers huh I like
it feels like an essence of corduroy but
not really you know who do you look down
the son just a little too long just
crinkled up you know nice it's hot
this is a sweater finally supply dad
hats or as I like to call them father
hats since I'm now an actual father I
get to wear a father hat well you don't
have to be a father to wear a dad hat
but if you wear one it does signify your
support for dads everywhere if you are a
dad or a fan of dads go support them by
sniping at corridor digital dad ad now
go to corridor digital comms last I keep
wanting to say shirt a little laugh
trying to get it out that one gets saved
you had the darkened chicken the
blackened chicken roast
wait I see what is it oh it's on Ali
Sonny what is it they're saying ma we
almost got I got laughing at it
beforehand didn't give it away
yeah it's the most pathetic I've ever
felt well it's game distort it was
pretty funny to see any content yeah a
flow tear and honestly just make ghost
gifts that's a good one
[Applause]
[Laughter]
probably a better place oh my god that's
pretty good where does it go from there
oh holy
[Music]
the Frick is happening dude this is
crazy
[Music]
[Applause]
French candles yeah
[Music]
[Music]
so we have a winner the official winner
of the third annual quarter gift contest
is Finley Durkin thank you for your
submission you guys submitted something
and we didn't see it posted on the
subreddit we'll go over there more we'll
take another gander and see what pops up
grats - Finley for being the third
annual contest winner this hat will be
passed to my son once he becomes a
father only ten days is your
limited-edition shirt is my favorite
sure we have ever made I'm serious
listen to this crisp clean clear audio
mmm also my favorite corridor shirt ever
thanks Jarrett the new store is live go
check it out there's a lot of great
shirts we got new baseball caps a lot of
you guys been asking for baseball caps
we got new shirts we got this sick anime
self-driving car shirt it's only
available for ten days you know you want
it if you don't get it now you'll be sad
forever click the link in the
description below check out the Korus
store digital x corridor comm slash
store